when I was a kid I was afraid of the
dark the darkness is where the monsters
I and I had this little nightlight
outside of my bedroom so they would
never get too dark but over time my fear
of the dark turned to curiosity what is
out there in the dark dark and it turns
out the trying to understand the
darkness something that's fascinated
humans for thousands of years maybe
forever and we know this because we find
there ancient relics of their attempts
to map the sky this tusk is over 30
thousand years old some people think
that it's a carving of Orion or maybe a
calendar we don't know the foushee star
map is over six thousand years old then
it's from a Neolithic tomb in ancient
China and that little pile of clam
shells underneath the dead guy's foot
the middle that's supposed to be the Big
Dipper
maybe the never disc is uncontroversial
you don't have to be an astronomer to
know that you're looking at the moon
phases or the Sun and eclipses and that
little group of seven stars
that's the Pleiades the Seven Sisters
but in any case the point is clear
astronomers have been mapping the sky
for a long time why it's our calling
card as a species in the galaxy to
figure things out
we know our planet we cure our diseases
we cook our food we leave our planet but
it's not easy understanding the universe
is battle it is unrelenting it is time
varying and it is one we are all in
together
it is a battle in the darkness against
the darkness which is why Orion has
weapons in any case if you're gonna
engage in this battle you need to know
the battlefield so at its core mapping
this guy involves three essential
elements you've got objects that are
giving off light
you've got telescopes that are
collecting that light and you've got
instruments that are helping you
understand what that light is so many of
you have mapped the moon phases over
time with your eyes your eyes being your
more basic telescope and you've
understood what that means with your
brains your brains being one of your
more basic instruments now if you and a
buddy get together you would spend over
thirty years you would map a thousand
stars extremely precisely you would move
the front lines of the battle and that's
what Tycho Brahe he and his buddy or his
assistant really Johannes Kepler did
back in the 1600s and they moved the
line figured out how planets worked how
they moved around the Sun but it wasn't
until about a hundred years ago that we
realized it's a big universe it seems
like the universe is just infinite which
it is but the observable universe is
finite which means we can win the battle
but if you're gonna map the universe
you're not gonna do it was one of two
your besties mapping the universe takes
an army an army of curious creative
craftspeople who working together can
accomplish the extraordinary I lead this
army of creatives in the fifth
generation of the Sloan Digital Sky
Survey SDSS and this is how astronomers
have managed to shepherd individual
curiosity through its Industrial Age
preserving the individual ability to
make discoveries but putting into place
mega machinery to truly advance the
frontier in sdss we did
by the sky into three mappers one for
the stars one for the black holes and
one for the galaxies my survey has two
hemispheres five ten five telescopes or
11 depending on how you count ten
spectrographs and millions of objects
it's a monster so let's go through the
mappers the Milky Way galaxy has 250
billion plus or minus a few hundred
billion stars that is not a number that
you hold in your head that is a number
that doesn't make practical sense to
pretty much anybody you never get 250
billion jellybeans in your hand you know
we're nowhere near mapping all of those
stars yet so we have to choose the most
interesting ones an SDS s5 we're mapping
six million stars where we think we can
measure their age because if you can
measure the age of a star that's like
having six million clocks spread all
throughout the Milky Way and with that
information we can unravel the history
and fossil record of our galaxy and
learn how it formed I'm just going to
cut right to the chase here black holes
are among the most perplexing objects in
the universe why because they are
literally just math incarnate in a
physical form that we barely understand
it's like the number zero being animated
and walking around the corridors here
that would be super weird
these are weirder and it's not just like
a basketball that you've smushed down
into a little point and it's super dense
and that's weird no smushed basketballs
have a surface these things don't have
surfaces and we know that now because
we've seen it or the lack of it what's
really interesting about black holes is
that we can learn a lot about them by
studying the material just as it passes
through that point of no information
return because at that point it's
emitting lots of x-rays and optical and
UV and radio waves we can actually learn
how these objects grow
and an scss we're looking at over half a
million supermassive black holes to try
to understand how they formed like I
said we live in the Milky Way you guys
are all familiar with that
the Milky Way is a completely average
galaxy nothing funny going on but it's
ours which is great we think that the
Milky Way and all the Milky Way's have
this really disturbing past of literally
blowing themselves apart it's like every
average guy you know has a history as a
punk rock teenager that's very bizarre
stars are blowing up in these systems
black holes are growing at their centers
and emitting a tremendous amount of
energy how does that happen how does
this transformation happen and an scss
we're going to the bellies of the beast
and zooming way in to look at these
processes where they are occurring in
order to understand how Sid Vicious
grows up into Ward Cleaver my arsenal
these are my two big telescopes the
Apache point observatory hosts the Sloan
telescope in New Mexico and the last
Campanas Observatory in Chile hosts the
two and a half meter telescope at the
DuPont two and a half meters is the size
of our mirror which was huge for Tycho
and Kepler but it's actually not so big
today they're way bigger telescopes out
there but an SCSS we use new instruments
on these old telescopes to make them
interesting we capture light from all of
those objects into into our aperture and
that light is then focused at the focal
plane where our instruments sit and
process that light what's new and SCSS
five is that we are making the focal
plane entirely robotic that's right
robots so I'm going to show them to you
but they're fierce and terrifying and I
want you all to just take a breath
trigger warning and with no apologies to
all the blade runner's among you here
they are I have a thousand of these 500
in the focal plane of each telescope in
each hemisphere and this is how they
move on the sky so these are our objects
and a star field so you've got stars
galaxies black holes and our robots move
to those objects as we pass over them in
order to capture the light from those
stars and galaxies and black holes and
yes it is weird to capture black hole
light but we've already gone over that
black holes are weird so one more thing
stars are exploding all the time like
this one did back in 1987 in our cosmic
backyard
black holes are growing all the time
there is a new sky every night which
means we can't just map the sky one
times we have to map the sky multiple
times so in SDS s5 we're going back to
each part of the sky multiple times in
order to see how these objects change
over time because those changes in time
and code the physics and they encode how
these objects are growing and changing
no this guy okay let me just recap
global survey two hemispheres five
telescopes ten spectrographs millions of
objects mow the sky creative army robots
yeah
so you're thinking wow she must have
this industrial machine going no room
for the individual curious lone Lewis
genius right and you'd be 100% wrong
meat ha nice work honey van Arkel was a
Dutch school teacher who was analyzing
the public versions of the sdss data
when she found this incredibly rare type
of object which is now a subject of
major study she was able to do this
because SDSS since its beginning and by
mandate from the sloan Foundation has
made its data both publicly available
and usable to a broad range of audiences
she's a citizen yeah he clapped for that
packet at handy's the citizen scientists
or as I like to call them citizen
warriors and she shows that you don't
have to be a fancy astrophysicist to
participate you just have to be curious
a few years ago my four-year-old asked
Ken moons have mint and I said about to
answer this question because even though
many four-year-olds over all of time
have probably asked this question many
experts including myself didn't know the
answer these are the moons in our solar
system that can host hypothetical sub
moons and that just goes to show you
that there are so many basic questions
left to be understood and this brings me
to the most important point about sdss
because yeah the Stars the galaxies the
black holes the robots
that's all super cool but the coolest
thing of all is that in C we see
creatures on a rubble pile around a
totally average star in a totally
average galaxy can win the battle to
understand their world every dot in this
video is a galaxy every dot
I'm showing here the number of galaxies
that astronomers have mapped in large
survey since about 1980 you can see a
CSS kick in around y2k if we stay on
this line we will map every large galaxy
in the observable universe by 2060 think
about that think about it we've gone
from arranging clam shells to general
relativity to SDSS in a few thousand
years and if we hang on 40 more we can
map all the galaxies but we have to stay
on the line will that be our choice
there are dark forces in this world that
will rob our entire species of our right
to understand our universe don't be
afraid of the dark
fight back join us thank you